at first glance the latest labor market
figures contain good news in the three
months to july unemployment fell to a
near 50-year low of just 3.6
that's the smallest proportion of people
who are looking for work but can't find
it it's way over here in 1974
but that doesn't tell the whole story of
what's going on in the jobs market
because there are still more than 1.2
million unfilled vacancies that's almost
as many as there are people unemployed
so the fall has more to do with this
economic inactivity that measures
everyone of working age who for various
reasons cannot or isn't trying to work
it's been increasing since the pandemic
and it's reached
21.7 that's almost 9 million people the
latest increase has been driven by a
rise in long-term sickness and students
and it means there are far fewer
potential workers for employers to draw
on now that gap between employer demand
and the supply of workers is pushing pay
higher on average by more than five
percent with inflation at more than 10
in real terms wages are falling you can
see here they're down 3.9 they can't
keep up with inflation and there's an
even bigger gap between public and
private sector pay with private sector
wages up on average six percent while
the public sector settles for just two
percent now all of this is driving
industrial disquiet and it means that
even as parliament and much of the
business of government has paused in
national mourning the cost of living
squeeze on workers goes on